[Musica]
come ti sei vestito perché non parli
grazie sei un mimo ok ma che cosa vuoi
vabbè senti non ha tempo di aspettare
quello che stai dicendo un no grazie ma
che siete a vitale impazzito investito
da mimo e non vuole parlare cosa vorrà
dire proviamo interpretare quello che
dice cioè non che dice quello che quello
che imita stai correndo stai portando
merlino guinzaglio
ok sbattuto ad un palo ad una vetrina ad
una finestra al muro cosa fai adesso
vorrei che sti sbattuto d'amburgo cosa
fai
ma aprendo lungo la cerniera un pomello
una porta stai attraversando la porta ok
comunque ti sei dimenticato di berlino
berlino rimasto qui a san vitale che c'è
sei hai sentito qualcosa hai preso no
sta provando a prendere qualcosa
ascoltando qualcosa una mosca da una
zanzara bru
un up and go una farfalla facendo non
hai piazzate volata via
ah meno male di cercare di staccare cosa
la colla ingredienti devo cercare gli
ingredienti slime dovrei cercare gli
ingredienti slime già ho tutto quello
che mi serve c'è nessun personaggio
strano da cui devo scappare quindi
perché dovrei cercare gli ingredienti
slime è rimasto uguale yo yo scappare
devo scappare io da te perchè
ehi per esempio cellulare io cercare
ingrediente of a ridarmi il cellulare
subito no fermo fermo per realmente
impazzito mi ha rubato il cellulare non
penso che voglia ridarmelo porta
poggiava su qualcosa tempo stai
aspettando che cosa sei affermando a me
sta schiattando mense va bene mister
mimmo se proprio non merita il cellulare
troverò gli ingredienti slime almeno
dammi qualche indizio dove posso trovare
il primo vediamo se riusciamo a capirlo
scrivete voi nei commenti si è riusciti
a capire qualcosa ai ricordatevi di
lasciare un mi piace se questo video se
volete vedere altri video trova gli
ingredienti slime se questo video
raggiunge i 20 mila mi piace il mimo
tornerà per un'altra caccia al tesoro
quindi la solita un bel mi piazzo primo
indizio o ingrediente ok a pau soluzione
per le ti sta slittando qualcosa
bicarbonato ok statua
qualcosa che si muove pendolo e il puc
sel sta volando e si è messo in posa si
è appoggiato ok ma che cos'è questo ho
fatto lo so un grande mai non offenderti
valori indovina subito dovrebbe essere
più bravo anche tu però ok bimbi dai
andiamo qualcosa prendendo ammazzato
qualcosa un albero è caduto un albero
ok non non è capito che cosa è tanto
cosa non riesco a capire è la cosa di
davvero del ciclo di dominato in albero
tutto questo tempo bellacosa era un
albero abbiamo indovinato dovrò
arrampicarmi sopra un albero bicarbonato
albero ma come faccio con una corda
arrampicandomi va bene però tu dovrai
accompagnarmi così poi aiutarmi nel caso
che cade dall'albero e andiamo in
giardino e vediamo se riusciamo a
trovare questo ingrediente sto con te se
gli alberi ma dove vige e ci è scappato
vediamo se sopra un albero in giardino
nessuno ti seguo al montana armi ma che
sta dicendo non capisco devo seguirlo o
allontanarmi ma che sto facendo il
percorso di berlino aiutami di miche
albero è questo vi dico questo questo
non è un albero mi stai prendendo in
giro
vediamo proviamo a cercare ok ma perché
mi stai seguendo 66 andare andiamo secco
non vedo niente
c'è qualcosa qua sopra
guardate e coloni l'ho trovato proviamo
a prenderlo o no è troppo in alto non
c'è cibo
senti non è che mi aiuteresti a
prenderla dalla soprano giardino bene
ragazzi già preso il primo ingrediente
facciamolo qua ora vediamo qual è
l'indizio per il secondo secondo
ingrediente girare mescolare bacchetta
che non era quella dario di offendere
spatola battola bastava dirlo no ok da
veli indizio zoe dove trovarla muro
grumello porta a porta a porta
forse una parola composta porta su porta
su supporta supporta ma che cos'è una
supporta la fuga forte di supposta non
riesco a capire che cosa vuol dire sta
continuando da solo senza che si porta
sopra sopra la porta la la capra campa
arriverà così sopra porta la piazza
campo
lo porta la cabrio o era sopra la panca
la capra ma cosa vuol dire sopra la
porta o dovrei cercare sopra alle porte
sopra la porta qua non c'è un bel niente
neanche qua sopra la porta non c'è
niente e nemmeno 4 avrà la porta non c'è
niente se sono io vi ho capito male
l'indizio un ufficio fino qualcosa di
blu vedete si vede pochissimo nella
sopra vediamo fresco no non ci arrivo ma
poi rimettere tutte le cose in alto
io sono bassa ei berlino aiutami tu ma
prendono da qua sopra aspetta
io ti dò mai niente tasca una corda
ok grazie proverò a usarla non
offenderti ma io non riesco proprio a
vederla questa corda lo so che strano
per te però vabbè provo comunque ad
usarla va bene da fa
che devo fare ora tirare
[Musica]
forse si è chiuso la porta cade ancora
la paletta anche il mimo e contento ok
terzo ingrediente terzo indizio
vediamo un po mescolare o chi occhiali
bottiglia su vita è perfetto
ok ora da milly indizio due parlare
sopra su
berlino che cos'è aiutami a capire vista
la reazione di berlino potrebbe essere
un gatto ok gatto con il topo 6 gatto e
topo quindi orecche proboscide elefante
ok cade dai non ti offendere non è colpa
mia per la musica per i suoi tre bebé e
sopra dormire dormire letto ma che stai
facendo
[Musica]
stai vedendo un tè
perché sì ma non riesco a capirlo da
ayman di capire meglio il tuo indizio
sopra letto marzo broletto subito sopra
letto giusto per vivere che ho fatto
ora non ci resta che controllare quanto
praga berlino
ok stiamo qua nell'essere di sopra passo
sopra letto si è voluto un po di tempo
per capire dopo che potrebbe essere peak
un gatto
elefante vediamo un po cosa nostra 6
abbiamo trovato un altro ingrediente ora
ne manca solo uno la colla ecco qua i
nostri tre ingredienti ma anche solo la
colla dei regimi pure dove 4 quarto
quarto indizio si sta risvegliando ti
guardi intorno
apre una porta scavalchi qualcosa apri
la finestra aria stai affacciando dalla
finestra merlino aiutami anche tu stai
capello qual è il quarto indizio
cornicione
guardi fuori all'orizzonte sei seduto a
bere un caffè apri la porta entra ti
guardi intorno rischiare di cadere
cadere cosa può essere più rischiare di
catherine balcone un burrone evaso nel
indizio ok allora andiamo nel balcone al
piano di sopra dovremmo trovare la colla
se sono riuscito a interpretare bene
quello che diceva il mimo non quello che
diceva quello che imitava il mimo
salendo al piano di sopra
andiamo andiamo ok eccoci qua si è
aperta la porta
[Risate]
ecco qua tutti gli ingredienti andiamo
creare il nostro slime super di
liberatore primo ingrediente colla oro
glitterato secondo con la argento
glitterato con la rosa glitterata
narrazione parlanti il carbonato
mescoliamo vediamo di che colore diventa
riuscito una sorta di colore dorato
glitterato wow che bello come brilla
[Musica]
signor mimo
ecco qua lo slime che è richiesto adesso
devi ridarmi il cellulare
zino fare finta di niente e sequestrato
le buttato dove novi stai prendendo in
giro di scomparsa ha lasciato il
cellulare compivo per noi ma trova il
cappello del mimo sei bellissimo abbiamo
vinto anche questo giallo insomma per
vedere le altre challenge ora cliccate
fune di queste quattro caselline se
volesse vedere altri video trova gli
ingredienti sly ma se volete vedere i
video divertenti se volete vedere
scherzi se volete vedere video paurosi
scegliete la casellina che preferite
buona visione